vamos con la actualización de las
noticias económicas y para ello me
acompaña mi compañera Daniela blanndona
Daniela saludo para usted nuevo Hola
Ángela Buenos días bueno hemos hablado
durante estos dos días acerca del
silicon Valley Bank y como el llamado a
la calma de Joe biden ayudó a los
inversionistas de esta entidad pero no
mucho al mercado bursátil y siendo así
pues yo le doy la palabra usted nos
tiene un invitado y toda una explicación
alrededor de lo que sigue ahora después
de Esta caída Claro que sí Ángela y Es
que hoy las bolsas están operando mixtas
porque por un lado está todo este tema
de la el colapso del silicon pero
también hay un dato de inflación en
Estados Unidos del 6% en febrero
interanual y esto nos da luces sobre lo
que va a ser la reserva Federal pero
para hablar sobre este tema vamos a
saludar a Héctor Mario Rodríguez él es
el director de primera página una
agencia de noticias colombiana hay que
hacer la cuña y fue donde yo empecé como
periodista económica lo vamos a decir
Hace cuántos años pero pues Héctor Mario
bienvenido y cuéntenos primero
Qué significa todo esto en qué estamos
de qué estamos hablando de esta quiebra
de este colapso es bancario bueno
Daniela gracias por la invitación a ver
Esto es algo que viene por la coyuntura
económica mundial que es muy volátil por
las circunstancia muy clara de la subida
de tasas de interés que se está
protagonizando por los bancos centrales
del mundo para detener la inflación todo
lo que pasó en la postpandemia y en la
pandemia o sea llevamos dos años
tratando de Recuperar el norte después
de lo que sucedió y viene esta quiebra
de un banco que viene a ser mediano 16
en Estados Unidos no es tan grande es un
banco boutique porque es un banco
especializado Pero hay un nerviosismo
generalizado porque puede ser el inicio
de una cosa más grande o puede ser una
simple coyuntura de nerviosismo de los
mercados como está ocurriendo en las
últimas horas eso es lo que se está
tratando de terminar y acerca del
mensaje de biden
dijo están seguros los depósitos Ese fue
el mensaje central pero lo segundo dijo
ojo que viene nueva regulación stronges
regulation quiere decir fuertes medidas
sobre el manejo de la banca y ya se está
hablando de fraude en ese banco pero
muchos han dicho hubo rescate o no hubo
rescate y En qué se parece esto la
crisis del 2008 hubo rescate total
rescate el la Norma que decía que los
depósitos de 250 mil dólares estaban
amparados ese del fondo de garantías
pero la medida fue adoptada directamente
con recursos del tesoro de Estados
Unidos quiere decir que no es solo el
fondo de garantía es el que actúa sino
el Ministerio de Hacienda Estados Unidos
que allá viene siendo el Ministerio de
Hacienda y segundo ahí además una línea
de la reserva Federal del Banco Central
de Estados Unidos Para apoyar a toda la
banca en general por si hay otras
posibilidades de liquidez y de hecho ya
van cuatro bancos ya tuvieron que apoyar
otro fin de semana y hay dos con fila Y
eso es lo que está causando el mayor
nerviosismo Y promete ser bastante
polémico por el tema de los rescates y
de que con recursos posiblemente de
contribuyentes estén Rescatando a la
banca
lo que dicen es que no se va a rescatar
con recursos de los bueno eso nos
dijeron aquí en el 99 y ahí está el
cuatro por mil pero lo cierto Es que
no se va a rescatar con recursos de los
contribuyentes el banco va a ser vendido
lo malo es que viene a vender a venderse
por un precio nominal y el que lo
rescate o se quede con él quiere
quedarse con el portafolio hay que
recordar que este es un banco que sí
tiene muchas peculiaridades boutique que
ayudaba a las empresas nuevas la estará
si todas estas cosas pero tiene un
problema de fondo tiene 40 años tenía un
problema tecnológico muy complicado
siendo el banco de la simtec tramitar un
crédito y todo era larguísimo y muy
complicado entonces no es un banco es un
banco con pies de barro se Ya se está
hablando de fraude claro y Héctor Mario
Quiero preguntarle para las personas en
Colombia por ejemplo o en Perú o en
Bolivia que no tienen nada que ver con
un banco en Estados Unidos es importante
este este colapso sí tienen que ver
Muchos colombianos y mucha gente de la
región ese banco además de prestar y de
intermediar en los créditos de los
venturies a las sintex y a estas
estarpas nuevas que hay en la región
tenía los depósitos de los billonarios
de la región es decir la gente que es
dueña de esas fintech y que se llenó de
plata con esos créditos también tiene
sus depósitos ahí y segundo Viene un lío
complicado para esas startups Porque esa
plata de sus nóminas y de sus venturies
y ese capital que ellos necesitaban
estaban en el banco van a dárselo pero
el problema es que van a tener problemas
para que haya nuevos créditos para
conocer al nuevo dueño del banco
bastantes complicaciones va a haber O
sea que si va a haber y ya hay nombres
ahí por ejemplo a New Bank le tocó salir
a decir yo no tengo ahí recursos y es el
único que ha dicho yo no tengo pero los
demás muy complicado no sabemos entonces
Cuáles son O sí sabemos pero no podemos
decir cuáles son los nombres de todas
estas empresas que se han visto
afectadas y que seguramente se verán
afectadas a lo largo de los próximos
días Ángela pues muchas gracias Daniela
Muchísimas gracias por hacernos todas
las explicaciones pertinentes y bueno
Esta es una noticia que seguro se va a
seguir desarrollando y nosotros
Seguiremos aquí con el análisis Muchas
gracias a nuestro invitado y a nuestra
periodista de economía vamos ahora en
directo a París